la economía en france 24 me acompaña en
el estudio àngel hablando con daniela
buena noche bienvenida en perú las tasas
de interés tendrán un tope hola raul
buenas noches este polémico proyecto que
lo establece lo aprobó el congreso en
diciembre pero el gobierno lo devolvió
ahora el legislativo adoptó la figura
llamada aprobación por inasistencia para
por insistencia mejor para ratificarlo
aunque aún cuando sea ley el gobierno
puede llevarlo al tribunal
constitucional la tasa de usura es un
tope que se les pone a los intereses que
cobran las entidades financieras en
casos como préstamos personales y para
pequeñas empresas también para tarjetas
de crédito ahora el banco central de
perú deberá fijar la cada seis meses
varios países de américa latina ya la
tienen raúl argentina chile colombia
nicaragua ecuador entre otros pero el
gobierno de francisco sagas y algunos
economistas dicen que el esquema nunca
ha funcionado en el mundo daniela ya que
en el primer mes del break si no le fue
bien a las exportaciones de lado y lado
del canal de la mancha
raúl desde el primero de enero comenzó
recordemos una nueva relación entre
londres y bruselas el primer balance es
que las exportaciones del reino unido de
la unión europea se desplomaron en 47%
en enero mientras tanto las del bloque
de los 27 hacia gran bretaña bajaron 28
8% eso quiere decir a grandes rasgos que
ha habido un golpe relativamente mayor
para reino unido nuestra corresponsal
luisa pulido nos amplió la información
este es el primer efecto tangible en la
economía británica después del break
city en enero las exportaciones a la
comunidad europea de bienes pero
especialmente de alimentos cayeron a
niveles récord esto por las nuevas
imposiciones de controles fronterizos y
también por la nueva burocracia el
sector más afectado es el de la pesca
con un 80 por ciento el gobierno ha
prometido ayudas para los pescadores
este es curiosamente un sector simbólico
en todo este proceso de la salida del
reino unido de la unión europea también
cayeron las exportaciones de lácteos en
un 50 por ciento y de carne en un 60%
cambiamos de información daniela españa
y portugal aprobaron paquetes de ayudas
para sus empresas
raúl el gobierno portugués anunció
apoyos por 7 mil millones de euros que
serán usados para extender programas
creados en 2020 como por ejemplo
flexibilidad fiscal para las empresas
ayudas para el alquiler de locales y
subsidios para trabajadores de la
cultura y el deporte entre los más
afectados
en españa' entretanto el gobierno aprobó
un plan de ayuda desde 11.000 millones
de euros el dinero será usado en
transferencias directas y
reestructuraciones de deuda por ejemplo
a los empresarios y autónomos que hayan
perdido una tercera parte de sus
ingresos se les va a conceder entre
4.000 y 200 mil euros para pagar deudas
y gastos fijos respectivamente así de
daniela en irán las autoridades intentan
ponerle freno a las crecientes apuestas
en línea raúl imagínense que en este
país los juegos de azar están prohibidos
por la ley islámica desde 1979 debido a
los daños sociales que supuestamente
causan sin embargo ahora más que nunca
en esta pandemia las apuestas en línea
están en pleno auge en el mundo e irán
no es la excepción la fiscalía dice que
todos los involucrados en estos juegos
son considerados criminales incluso
quienes entreguen sus datos bancarios
para participar en ellos el congreso
decidió tomar cartas en el asunto está
estudiando castigos más severos para
quienes participen en esta actividad que
se estima mueve
mil millones de dólares por año
indicadores daniela los dos principales
índices de wall street el dow jones de
industriales- y el standard and poor's
renovaron sus récords al cierre de la
semana hay optimismo por la recuperación
económica que también se notó en europa
como londres madrid y francfort y en
américa latina las bolsas cerraron
dispares y méxico cerró una semana de
solo ganancias para finalizar ya que nos
trae como cifra el día es una cifra
deportiva raúl ya 80 millones de euros
en acciones que sacó a la bolsa de nueva
york uno de los dueños principales del
manchester united esto después de
conocerse que el equipo británico tiene
una deuda de 530 millones de euros en
parte por la pandemia y hablando de
fútbol le tengo otra el lyon uno de los
equipos de francia como no tiene con qué
pagarles el salario a los jugadores les
va a pagar con acciones vamos a ver
estas acciones en unos años más
mariela muchísimas gracias entonces por
toda la información como siempre ustedes
también gracias buena noche continúen
con nosotros
[Música]